on an ordinary day in 1991 a young man
known by the initials js went on a hike
with four of his friends on the wooded
outskirts of their small town
everything seemed perfectly normal until
js began to feel a strange sense of
familiarity
like he had been in this spot before he
couldn't shake this weird feeling
but thought nothing more of it little
did he know that this was a sign of
deadly things to come
several hours after first experiencing
that sense of deja vu
js was found by the side of the road
covered in cuts and scratches
with his friends nowhere to be found
this is the story of scp-939
an unforgettable monster that you'll
never remember
there was no way for js to know that the
unsettling feeling he felt and the
horrors that followed it
were the result of an experiment
conducted by the scp foundation
an experiment with deadly unforeseen
consequences
js and his friends were exposed to a
substance known only as
amnc227 as part of a series of tests
performed by the scp foundation
intended to determine the effectiveness
of this substance as a deliberate
amnestic dealing with as many mysterious
secret creatures and objects as they do
the scp foundation has long needed a way
to tamper with the memories of those
exposed to the foundation's various
prisoners and test subjects
and when the foundation discovered
amnc227
it seemed like it might be perfect for
this purpose
so where did amnc227 come from
over a year before the incident with js
and his friends the scp foundation
captured
scp-939 scp-939 is a species of
endothermic predators that live and hunt
in packs they are designated ketter
class and regarded as highly dangerous
and hostile to human life
native to caves they have no eyes
translucent red skin
and stand at an average of 2.2 meters
tall with an
average weight of 250 kilograms they
have four limbs
each ending in three fingered claws and
a fourth opposable digit resembling a
thumb
in addition to their sharp claws their
mouths are filled with red fang-like
teeth that reach up to six centimeters
in length
in place of their absent eyes they have
light-sensitive spots running along
their backs
which are covered in spines believed to
detect changes in air pressure and flow
in addition to their many other
terrifying attributes the internal
anatomy of scp-939
poses a biological mystery these
creatures have no circulatory system and
no digestive tract
that's right in spite of being predators
seemingly acting on a need to feed
they have no stomach instead when they
eat their food builds up in their
respiratory system
until its presence inhibits function and
then it is regurgitated
in spite of being a creature that should
not under any logical conditions be able
to live
scp-939 continues to persist and is even
capable of giving birth to live young
after a gestation period of 12 months
the scp foundation was able to study a
litter of these young that were born in
captivity in september of 1992
though the creatures remain just as much
of a scientific mystery as they were
upon first discovery everything about
them seems to defy the logic of the
natural world
which to be fair is really nothing new
for the foundation
the respiratory system of scp-939 was
found to exhale small traces of an
airborne amnesic substance
given the name amnc227 this compound
blocks the formation of memories for the
duration of exposure to it
plus a 30 minute period following the
exposure give or take a few minutes
it is colorless odorless tasteless and
completely undetectable in the
bloodstream after only
60 minutes amnc227 was approved for use
as a class c amnesic by the scp
foundation in 1990 following some
initial tests
however after one particular incident
involving a young man and his friends
the official use of amnc227 was
suspended
js and three of his four friends were
previously given a dose of amn c227
though the details of why they were
given the amnestic has since been
stricken from the record
several months after being exposed to
amn c227
js and his friends went out on their
ill-fated hiking trip
while hiking js was suddenly overcome
with the sense of deja vu
when he mentioned it to his friends
three of them agreed that they had felt
it too
one of the group another young man who
had not been exposed to amnc 227 was
uncomfortable
and decided to go home js and the
remaining three members of the group
made the choice to stay in the woods and
try to determine what was triggering the
unusual feeling of familiarity
as they got closer and closer to a large
cave near the hiking trail
the sense of having been there before
grew stronger and stronger
armed with only one flashlight and a
foolish curiosity
the four went inside the cave they made
their way deeper
and deeper and deeper into the darkness
not knowing why they felt this way
or what they might find inside none of
the group could explain
just what felt so familiar only that the
further they made their way into the
cave
the more pronounced the feeling became
it was getting late
and they knew they should have been
afraid to venture so deep into a cave
with only one light source
and no knowledge of what lay inside but
still
they pressed on one of the group
remarked that they should turn back
but the others refused to listen they
wanted to know what they were getting
close to
what was drawing them deeper and deeper
into the cave
unfortunately for them they would get
their answer
in the heart of the cave was a pack of
scp-939
waiting patiently for their prey to
wander into their domain
there are no witnesses to account for
what exactly happened to js and his
companions
but we can reasonably piece the events
together from what happened after
once the friends reached the heart of
the cave the creatures were on them in
seconds
raking them with their sharp claws and
biting with their fangs
scp-939 are larger and stronger than
most people
so it was probably not much of a fight
however while his friends were being
devoured
js was somehow able to scramble out of
the cave and make his way
into the woods in search of help under
the influence of the amc 227 that had
built up in the cave from the presence
of the pack of scp-939
js lost a large portion of his memory of
the event
he found himself on the side of the
highway late at night seriously injured
and his clothes ripped
an officer found him there and asked him
to stay still and remain calm until an
ambulance could arrive
js was still in a panic and attempted to
run away from the officer
begging to be released so that he could
get away he babbled incoherently about
the color red
screaming over and over again about the
red though when prompted
he could not explain what the red he was
screaming about referred to
his friends were not with him just as
the officer managed to calm js
the ambulance arrived its flashing red
light sent him into another frenzy
and he attempted to escape custody
claiming that the red lights were going
to get him
the official police report described js
as perhaps being under the influence of
a powerful hallucinogen
that he was just having a bad trip but
the scp foundation
knew better the foundation conducted an
interview with js about his experience
and determined that scp-939 was
certainly involved
as part of their cover-up effort they
strongly implicated js in the
disappearance and the death of his
friends
he was convicted of manslaughter that
the bodies of his friends were never
found
it is rumored that the scp foundation
hired him on a prison work release
program
and that he now works as a member of the
janitorial staff at one of the
foundation's facilities
this incident led to the suspension of
the use of amnc227
as it revealed some vital and disturbing
information about the compound's side
effects
after the exposure to amnc227 a person
who found themselves exposed to it again
would experience a sense of familiarity
and felt compelled to investigate the
source of this feeling
essentially anyone treated with amnc227
are not made aware of the existence
and danger of scp-939 would become a
perfect victim
primed to be attracted to dens of
scp-939
it is likely that this side effect is
not a coincidence but rather a
deliberate hunting tactic designed to
attract prey
that had somehow managed to escape with
no memory of their attack at the hands
of scp-939
this previous intended prey would find
themselves drawn to the same den or even
a new one
not knowing that they were walking back
into near certain death
while the scp foundation suspended the
use of amnc 227 as a class cmnestic
they did recruit a team of scp field
operatives to take advantage of this
side effect
this team of operatives were
deliberately administered a dose of amnc
227
and briefed on its effects as well as
the dangers of following the feeling of
deja vu
should its surface in the field these
infected officers were essentially used
as bloodhounds
relying on any sense of unusual
familiarity to sniff out new dents of
scp-939
so they could be captured and contained
by the foundation
as far as we know this operation is
still ongoing today
however now that the foundation has a
sufficient number of specimens to study
additional dens of scp-939 that are
discovered are ordered to be immediately
destroyed
as for the scp-939 still in captivity
they are contained in environmentally
regulated and negatively pressured cells
with walls of reinforced concrete the
doors to the cells are airtight to
prevent the leakage of any amnc227
and any personnel that interact with one
of the creatures is required to wear
level c
hazmat gear to avoid exposure and follow
decontamination procedures upon
exiting the cell all scp-939 have
subdermal tracking devices implanted to
find them in the event of escape
only one scp-939 has given birth in the
time that the creatures have been in
captivity strangely
scp-939 young look indistinguishable
from human infants
and change their physical appearance at
some yet unknown point as they age
if any more offspring are produced they
will immediately be separated from the
parent and studied
all that we know is that they are found
in caves in the woods outside of a small
town
it could be any town even yours so
if you're ever out hiking and struck
with a sudden feeling of deja vu
don't investigate don't get curious
just go home it might just save your
life
you